はじめ：こんにちは！はじめしゃちょーと
サンダー：いよぉぉぉっす！！俺だ！！サンダーだ！！
オックン：どうもオックンです
サ：おぉ
は：我々よく遊んでますよね
サ：はい オ：はい
は：はい
は：もうすぐ新発売のカードが
あるんですけども！
は：それを今回いち早く！
我々で
遊んでみましょう！！！
サ：なるほど～！やっていこう！
は：はい！
は：で、遊戯王ちょっと分かんないって方も
いると思うので
ちょっと我々なりに
分かりやすく！楽しく！かっこよく！！！
は：みんなでも理解できるように
やっていきたいと思うので
サンダーさんと僕で
戦っていきましょう！！！
は：せっかくなんでちょっと
水溜りボンドの２人にも来てもらって
トミー：この石灰マンでだいじょぶですかね
ト：はいどうも水溜りボンドです
カンタ・ト：お願いします！
ト：トミーです
カ：カンタです
カ・ト：お願いします！
は：お2人にも
遊戯王カードぜひ覚えてもらいたい サ:やってもらおう
は：見てもらおっか、２人の(はじめんとサンダーさん)
サ：そうだね
カ：あ～ぜひぜひぜひ ト：あ～なるほど、じゃあそうっすね
は：見る、見る、見るだけで
カ：あ～もうでも、それですぐ分かる
視聴者目線でいればいい？
は・サ：そうそうそう
ト：あ～たしかにたしかに
は：見ててもらえれば良いと思うんで　カ：はいはいはい
は：やっていきますか！
カ：お願いします
ト：お願いします　サ：おっけーい
全員：デュエル！！！
（はじめん）
（オックンwww）
（傍観者となった水溜りボンド）
デュエル！
サ：先攻は俺からいかせてもらおう
サ：俺のターン！
サ：俺は甲虫装機(インゼクター) ダンセルを召喚！
は：なに！！？
は：甲虫装機(インゼクター)だと？！
カ・ト：インゼクター？？
（カンタがダンセルになってしまった）
ダンセル(カンタ)：いやおかしいでしょ絶対に
ト：お前先輩にそんなことすんなよ？お前　　　　　カ：絶対おかしいでしょ
は：甲虫装機(インゼクター) ダンセルだと！！？
サ：さらに俺はカードを２枚セットして
ターンエンド！
〔サ：大丈夫、２枚セットしてあるから〕
〔カ：大丈夫っすか？ サ：だいじょぶだいじょぶ〕
〔サ：大船に乗ったつもりでいて〕
は：俺のターン！
ドロー！
は：俺は手札からツインツイスターを発動！
は：俺は手札を１枚捨て、
フィールドの魔法･罠(トラップ)カードを２枚破壊する!
サ：ごめん　カ：え、なんすか？
サ：後ろなくなっちゃった
は：俺は
魔界発現世行きデスガイドを召喚！
は：このカードが召喚に成功したとき、
デッキから悪魔族を１体連れてくる！
は：彼岸の悪鬼 グラバースニッチ！
カ・サ：彼岸！？？
は：そして俺は
デスガイドと
グラバースニッチで
エクシーズ召喚！！！！！
カ・サ：エクシーズ召喚！？？！
ト：エクシーズ召喚！！？！？
は：彼岸の旅人 ダンテ！！
（トミーがダンテになっちゃった）
ダンテ(トミー)：ちょっと待ってください
ト：これ大丈夫すか？僕
は：ダンテ攻撃表示だ！
ト：いや分かるんすけど
は：そしてダンテの効果発動！
ト：いや進んじゃったよ
は：Ｘ(エクシーズ)素材を１つ取り除き、
デッキの上から３枚を墓地へ送る！
は：そして
ダンテの攻撃力は
墓地に送ったカードの枚数×500ポイントアップする！
ト：なんか強くなったぞ俺
は：ダンテの攻撃力が1500アップ！
ト：たぶん強い笑
は：いくぜ
バトルフェイズ！
は：彼岸の旅人 ダンテでダンセルに攻撃！！
ト：おっなんか
言い残すことはないか？
カ：大丈夫っす、もう、なんか
サ：なんもない！！！
サ：ダンセルが受ける！
は：いけーー！　サ：ダンセルが受ける！
ト：ダアァッ！　カ：ああああぁぁぁ...
カ：うわあぁぁぁぁぁ...
サ：ダンセルゥゥゥ！！
は：そしてダンテはバトルフェイズ終了時に守備表示になる
は：守備表示だ
ト：こうかな？
ト：こんな感じかな？
は：このままターンエンド！
サ：くっ
俺のターン！
ドロー！
サ：俺はもう１体の
甲虫装機(インゼクター)ダンセルを召喚！
は・ト：またダンセルだと！！？
カ：またダンセルだと！？？
サ：ダンセール
出番、出番
カ：また？
サ：はよはよ
こっから忙しくなるから
ｰ甲虫装機(インゼクター)デッキの特徴ｰ 〈声:はじめ〉
モンスターにモンスターを装備する動きで
フィールドに大量の
甲虫装機(インゼクター)モンスターが並んでしまった
サ：そして俺のフィールドには
昆虫族が３体！
サ：俺はダンセルとセンチピードで
は・カ・ト：リンク召喚？？！
サ：現れろ！
甲虫装機(インゼクター) ピコファレーナ！！
・・・・・・。
カ：まじっすか
サ：うん
カ：ちょっと変わったんすね
サ：ふふふ、うん
カ：いいっすよ
サ：きれいだよ
リンク召喚されたピコファレーナは〈声:はじめ〉
さらに
甲虫装機(インゼクター)の動きを
加速させたのであった！
サ：甲虫装機(インゼクター)を装備しているおかげで
俺のセンチピードの攻撃力は2600！
ピコファレーナの攻撃力は3200に上昇！
は：やばい...
このままでは...
俺のモンスターたちが！
サ：いくぜ！バトルフェイズ！
サ：センチピードでスカラマリオンに攻撃！
は・ト：スカラマリオォォォ～ン！！
サ：続いて！
サ：パワーアップしたピコファレーナで
ダンテを攻撃！！
（クルクルクル）
サ：いけ～
（ピロリロリーン！！！）
ト：いてぇ！！！
は：ダンテエエエエエェェェェェェ！！！！
サ:強化した俺の甲虫装機(インゼクター)には勝てまい!
サ：ターンエンドだ！
は：くそっ...
は：どうすればいいんだ...
は：俺のターン
は：ドロー！！！
は：ふっはっはっはっ(不敵な笑み)
は：俺は！
は：ハーピィの羽根箒(ぼうき)発動！
は：相手の魔法･罠(トラップ)カードを全て破壊する!!
俺のハーピィの羽根箒で装備カードを失った今、〈声:はじめ〉
絶好の攻めるチャンスだ！
そして
新たな力！
リンク召喚！
は：リンク召喚！
は：彼岸の黒天使 ケルビーニ！！！
（にわとりかわいい）
（ライオンかわいい）
ト：いっやちょっと勘弁してくださいww
は：いや･･･w
は：リンクモンスターだぜ
ト：牛引けるんすよ
（ジジジ...）
は：いっやいやいやwwwww
ト：www
は：ケルビーニ！！！
ト：ケルビーニ！じゃないっすよ、もう
彼岸の黒天使ケルビーニは〈声:はじめ〉
彼岸モンスターたちをさらに強化し、
俺はさらなるモンスターを
召喚した！
は：彼岸の鬼神 ヘルレイカー！！！！
は：覚悟はいいか？(イケボ)
は：バトルフェイズ！！！
は：ヘルレイカーでセンチピードに攻撃！！！！
サ：くそぉぉぉ～！
は：さらに！
は：ベアトリーチェでピコファレーナに攻撃！！！！
サ：くそぉぉぉ～～！！(高音)
カ：うわああぁぁ...
（ドサッ）
（チーーーン）
は：そして！
は：ケルビーニ！
は：ダイレクトアタァァァック！！！
ト：（ん？）
ト：（んん？）
は：ダイレクトアタック！
ト：ダイレクトアタック...
は：ダイレクトアタァァック！！
ト：ダイレクトアタックゥゥゥ！
サ：アッッ
は：はいっ！
は：というわけで今回はですね
ト：甲虫装機(インゼクター)ピコファレーナね
は：モンスターとして出てきてもらいました
は：ありがとうございました！！
カ：あ～ありがとうございます！
カ：また次あったら呼んでください
wwwwww
は：はい！というわけで
遊戯王ルールが変わりました！
で！
は：今回のパックで
今までのあったテーマも
強化されて
より楽しめるようになったので
は：ぜひみなさん、遊んでみてください！
は：そしてなんと！
カ・ト・サ・オ：おぉ～～
は：あるみたいでございます！
は：みなさんぜひ、動画の概要欄から！
チェックしてみてくださ～い！
は：はい、というわけで
は：僕のイチオシテーマ 彼岸も
ちょっと強化されてとても嬉しかったです！
は：みなさんぜひ遊んでみてくださ～い！
は：バイバ～イ ! ! !　ト：ありがとうございました！